tardes como decíamos weinstein ya fue
condenado a 23 años por la justicia de
Nueva York que se puede esperar de este
nuevo proceso que empieza mañana en Los
Ángeles
yo creo que nos espera menos de lo que
ocurrió en Nueva York querida Rosa
buenas tardes buenas tardes a la
audiencia y es un caso simbólico un
hombre un macho alfa literal un macho
alfa en la Meca del cine norteamericano
que abusó de su poder que violó que
abusó sexualmente de muchas mujeres
ansiosas y de hacer carrera en la
industria cinematográfica y el abuso de
ese poder entonces Bueno sobre todo
Quiero recalcar la parte simbólica no
creo que le vaya mejor que en Nueva York
el camino ya está hecho lo que se espera
es que las mujeres se queden calladitas
este era una manera aceptable de ser
hombre en las Industrias del
entretenimiento Pero ahora ya no y aquí
las consecuencias querida Rosa
precisamente usted decía que ya no es
aceptable entonces Le quiero preguntar
precisamente por el contexto Por qué
significó el caso de weinstein tanto en
los progresos en términos de derechos
para las mujeres como en a posibles
retrocesos
Mira querida rosa es un caso simbólico
Sin lugar a dudas por por el calado de
la importancia de este hombre
nosotras en el feminismo en América
Latina
creíamos en un momento dado que con que
quedara todo escrito en blanco y negro
es decir en las leyes ya podríamos
avanzar en lo que se refiere a los
Derechos Humanos de las mujeres sin
embargo las situaciones nos están
indicando que no es solo que no solo
basta que esté en las leyes de todos los
países escrito con letras de oro como yo
digo Incluso en el congreso la Haz la
equidad en los derechos de las mujeres
sino que tenemos que cambiar
cultural y socialmente que este hombre
dedicado especialmente a lo cultural a
lo social el impacto social que este
hombre tenía pues es un paradigma Sin
lugar a dudas es un paradigma querida
Rosa y usted hablaba precisamente de los
feminismos en América Latina cree que
aquí el movimiento por los derechos de
las mujeres en el Continente el
subcontinente latinoamericano se vio
influenciado por el caso del mitú o que
fue un movimiento que se limitó a la
Esfera de Hollywood sin lugar a dudas
permeó en toda la en toda latinoamérica
las norteamericanas nos abrieron la
posibilidad de no quedarse calladas
todas estas mujeres que durante años
durante muchísimos años se quedaron
calladas aguantando los abusos Ahí están
los abusos por ejemplo de Plácido
domingo cuando venía de gira acá a
América Latina era muy bienvenido Pero
había mujeres que se ponían a temblar
cada vez que Plácido domingo llegaba a
su tierra de a su tierra a una gira
entonces Sí definitivamente la decisión
del mito en Estados Unidos abrió acá se
habló de un mito en México como sea de
haber hablado del mito en otros países
de latinoamérica pero pero tendríamos
querida Rosa que pasar de este primer
paso de no solamente denunciar sino que
las leyes que seguramente como en México
todo está escrito en las leyes
simplemente que haya la voluntad
política de hacerlas cumplir como
ocurrió allá en Nueva York querida